I
okay batches okay [ __ ] it's your boy
psychobabble here and we are gonna be
playing some last of us now um hello
Chester that's okay let's not be Sally
about this how you doing oh man well man
that's kind of weird yeah I don't know
what finest moments but I n'est pas sure
ok ok a little cabin I love cabin look
nightly reload their specially realizes
oh this [ __ ] gotta be a bit longer
that's for a shopback fresh shot yep
well it's a that's the radio tower room
dude I sure hope nobody in there meet at
vicinity and all of [ __ ] in the city at
Pittsburgh thought of that I got that
cat guy you're my little satan my little
saying hey
I said jet well I got a big [ __ ] map
here did with [ __ ] I don't even know
where to [ __ ] go okay let's just at
luton houses you know you do the old
classic Hurricane Katrina just taught
Luanne that's the way you gotta do it
[ __ ] oh I'll take this i guess i can't
thank ya okay anything over here ain't
[ __ ] over there good good ok that is
that all the scissors it says all right
here oh yeah babe asa my lap that big
this one more for daddy yes Chet Rama
jack hello he says I guess I'll pom
maker huh this place like without
infected uh I know is there I'm more
annoying you shouldn't affect he get
some quiet you know except for the clock
and clickers but applied tickle take him
out okay in here yeah
we met on Craigslist like that's I just
needed a friend looting now aunt rated
pots now that wasn't a good idea anyway
okay then good here still trying to
build my casio watch oh hello this bench
I need that name give me that give me
that oh it's like a [ __ ] rifle hey
let this [ __ ] yes thank ya thanks Alan
a scissors thank you yeah what else can
I make where this [ __ ] right yeah the
procedures always make wanna help kit
and make a lot of whoop it's you know
the best defense is I got all fences but
I say that's what I've been saying off
of my campaign how says that not good
yeah there's like wine a-rod you know
was it saying I have a gun you look I
shoot the [ __ ] kill your dog is
I guess I can't hear that I'm ARB
doctors will shoot on sight hey that's
how i can write it write this house
anything in here remember any of that
job huh I was just 5 when the cordyceps
it Carter how son of that drug I
remember living in a neighborhood just
like this what do you remember
bbqs pairs they would throw these crazy
before I'm Kings invited some people
okay okay no needs are all her up okay
how's that guy's name Jimmy oh [ __ ]
you're gonna want to stay away from
those it's not like it is in the zone
these are wild we get him did I get him
what is this Oh take out yeah Henry told
me about these until ice cream out of
the truck what no way it's joe it's true
but the hill buddy says it's all true
here we go oh I need one for pistol
right oh okay is that good as I'm
walking out o Shah day Brad
guess the load screen like this has a
real of bodies for you soon so I guess
[ __ ] about race car I give a single [ __ ]
okay this is guy that looks good okay
okay
I got got got got more parts of my watch
okay okay no no over here nothing
nothing okay
I can't thank ya i think that's not like
this
oh sure and we look in here and get dvds
and he Adam Sandler miss you know what's
a great well he grown ups one and tell
like a grown-up Swan was amazing and
grown ups 2 was just like yeah better
break when we get to the radio okay okay
that's Cape Town I guess there's a lot
of [ __ ] though I could sound like all
diluting I thought that's a good idea oh
I'm gonna jump down I don't Scott this
first letter sent it up okay [ __ ] it a
sniper did you see where can I some on
the street right now y'all stay here no
before you start I need you guys to keep
him busy I'm gonna go around and I see
if I can't get the angle on him okay
okay hey be careful oh you bet your
house i'll be careful betch Oh what gum
you [ __ ] like an [ __ ] how far can I
throat
och and running wait wasn't you were
going che is this gonna shoot me isn't
he ok that car is not gonna save you
this guy's a little crazy a little like
batshit crazy crazy just see what i
could be from here it's [ __ ] here all
right Howard how Jesus a hell is a candy
bar makes me feel a little better you
know
oh [ __ ] Jesus and that dancer huh I will
admit that a guy right there [ __ ] can't
tell what's going on here there's a
[ __ ] years and Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
I call me to shot gem okay yeah but I
really Oh ain't nothing to reload with
ok ok I make anything real quick [ __ ]
with eight this [ __ ] okay all right
let's see here where's that psycho damn
it where'd he go hell are you
oh [ __ ] that was [ __ ] up god I met
that was a little dark does she for you
too
oh [ __ ] ok not due until hot I will
admit no it's gone that way
chant gotta read aloud move up I dare ya
betch um come on come on come on [ __ ]
come on daddy's here daddy's waiting for
you come on miss a lil bit that's a
little bit for daddy a [ __ ] yep I shoot
his gun
again
holly [ __ ] i just [ __ ] wasted it God
God God
ouch this is getting a [ __ ] messy I do
not like how this is being played out
[ __ ] stop there where's that [ __ ] what
a [ __ ] torture he's up there I know
the [ __ ] is up there I got a nice drink
I'm gonna pour for you [ __ ] nice drink
are you he's in here isn't he oh yeah
daddy fat got done jumping like a blade
flick the blade oh [ __ ] who's shooting
at them jet I am not good at this come
on [ __ ] a gud gud gud ok I'm glad that
happened I guess it's a learning
experience it's a learning experience as
he jumps down i'm gonna [ __ ]
oh great come on hey ho snack stairs
next oh great his next hey shooting on
who this shitty huh that oh you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding i said i was doing
really well there
oh it was a guy over there my note my
name is John hairy legs I go four legs
come on shall shut or they should add
over here what do I
come
what am I supposed to be doing here yet
oh shut [ __ ] he's dead shut what am I
supposed to be shooting out here
not exactly sure oh there we go come on
[ __ ] oh I got it
oh that was intense she's out of [ __ ]
nuts okay thanks Joel at any time look
at this all right we did it I see you
like you know I'll kill you right here
should I kill him check on Sam Henry a
shut
come on come on let's move what what is
that
oh [ __ ] that's when I got to get rid of
clock an egg I mr. better bet [ __ ] this
is not good you're okay still here
anybody hurt oh good because said we
quit this place come on uh yeah I taste
that I'd say it's okay Jamie that's easy
yes sneak on out oh okay Jack there shut
the hell up I hate really well series
was Tommy's birthday it's all he wanted
to do is print to Harley's and drive
cross-country oh man I could die happy
if I could just write one around the
block what was it like yeah it's good
real good good can't believe this guy
come on man give me details describe it
you know what you two deserve a little
privacy ramasammy Ellie this isn't just
any regular motorcycle okay you get on
that bad boy you feel that engine
nothing like it yeah I'll tell your head
how would you know seen it in my dreams
oh yeah I got Lanka like it up [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't think anyone's my
group is gonna show up yeah where's part
about it all explaining it to Sam
well it's safe to say those two have
officially bonded what about yes huh
what are you doing is a again stock of
all the food we found today I see oh
[ __ ] is having on canned peaches I cried
good did Henry send you know wow it
Henry sent me to make sure i'm not
[ __ ] up somehow not that i'd say we
all did pretty good back there
especially you may recall did you know
you should give her more cons is
everything all right isn't in fact that
yeah everything's fine if I fact that
okay we got a quelle um well have a good
night hit shots knowing huh how is it
that you're never scared ah associate is
that I'm not what are you scared of us
Pettis oh let's see what else scorpions
are pretty creepy um being by myself I'm
scared of ending up alone okay what
about you those things out there what if
the people are still inside that match
what if they're trapped in there without
any control of their body those extra
man am scared of that happening to me
okay first of all we're team now okay
we're gonna help each other out and
second they might still look like people
but that person is not in there anymore
god I gotta cut Henry says that they've
moved on that they're with their
families like in heaven
do you think that's true I go back and
forth I mean I like to believe it but
you don't I guess not yeah me neither
okay oh well the serious talk almost
forgot well I uh oh sure I was looking
for that he doesn't know about it you
can't take it away all right I'm pooped
you know I'll see you tomorrow a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's infected okay right add God
God God God God damn that smells good
morning where's Sam I'll let him sleep
in for once oh well if you wanted to
join us you can go wake his ass up oh
[ __ ] Sam [ __ ] is turning
oh listen [ __ ] my brother screw it
really yeah you're right uh-huh oh my
god how's that oh no see oh Henry look
stay here Henry I'm gonna get that gun
for me okay oh ok he's sad you [ __ ] this
is nobody's fault him it's all your
fault Henry Henry know okay okay and
then there I tell Loretta
okay i guess i guess haunted Thank You
Raja ditch out for her Amish